the problem is that there's been a huge
backlog in the nhs about one in nine of
us one in nine of us is on an nhs
waiting list in this country six million
people or more huge numbers and
unfortunately that number is going to
keep going up so
we we're doing all sorts of things to
clear the covered backlogs and we're
putting about 8 billion pounds more into
into electives
as you know we're hiring 50 000 more
nurses
where we've got about 45 000 more people
working in the nhs
now
than there were last year and on top of
that we're now working with the nhs to
set some some tough targets so that we
are able to deliver
uh for patients and also for the
taxpayer because as you know we're
putting huge sums in
were the treasury concern that those
targets weren't tough enough to be
announced today
well no the what we've got is a uh some
things we can say today uh and we're
gonna be producing more in the course of
the of the week but
uh what we can say already is that we
want to make sure that
when it comes to cancer and i'm here in
the kent and medway oncology center
where they've done an amazing job and
they've kept going
really very fast throughout the pandemic
and they've kept the levels of treatment
up
virtually
as the same as they were before
covid but we want everywhere in the
country to match that success so what
we're saying is we want the vast
majority of people who think they may
have cancer
to have a diagnosis either confirming or
confirming that they do or that they
don't
have cancer within 28 days so we want
three and four to to have that
and we're also saying that by march of
23 by by spring next year we want nobody
to be waiting more than two months we've
got we and those are those are very
tough targets we've got to make sure
that the the nhs delivers them